الدبابات ابرز الامريكيه كهذه ستسلم الى
اوكرانيا قبل نهايه العام دبابات تشمل
ذخيره تحتوي على اليورانيوم المنطب حزمه
مساعدات امنيه جديده اذا بقيمه تصل الى
175 مليون دولار
اليورانيوم المنظف هو ناتج ثانوي عن عمليه
تخصيب اليورانيوم يقول معارض استخدامه الى
هناك مخاطر صحيه بالغه من استنشاق او
ابتلاع غبار اليورانيوم المنضب تشمل
الاصابه بالسرطان في منشور على تيليجرام
وصفه روسيا القراره بغير الانسان
تزويد الولايات المتحده ذخيره دبابات
باليورانيوم المنظم لاوكرانيا دليل واضح
على عدم انسانيتها واشنطن مهووسه بفكره
انزال هزيمه استراتيجيه بروسيا ومستعده
للقتال ليس فقط حتى اخر اوكرانيا لكن ايضا
للقضاء على اجيال المستقبل سبق للجيش
الامريكي ان استخدم اليورانيوم المنضب في
حرب الخليج وكذلك عند قصف الناتو السابقه
من جانبها حثت الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه التابعه للامم المتحده على توخي
الحذر بشان استخدامه وحذرت من مخاطر
استنشاق اليورانيوم المنطب